you know you're a comedian at the root
of it there's like the the consciousness
is the
is the twist yeah you know so the the
marriage was uh
a clumsy orgy in the beginning
so you know the these two parts of me
were more separated just like i
mentioned like i can be serious life
coaching and i can be funny in my
personal life
but i had never let him coexist so i'll
give you an
internal answer first which will sound
super abstract and airy theory and it
won't matter then i'll
give a practical answer so the internal
answer
the work i had to do was integrate these
parts of me
so essentially metaphorically speaking
take my inner child out of the basement
where i had thrown him for 13 years and
said
you stay in the basement because you
will screw up my professional life
you're flawed like that was a
shame-based message i was telling myself
so i had to take him out of the basement
and basically say like
i'm sorry i believe that each and every
one of us has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the show is jp and amber sears
they are married
they have the same purpose and goals in
life but accomplish them in different
ways
so it was fun to talk about how they
arrived at the place that they're at
now with jp being what he would call a
conscious comedian
and amber is a business coach now and
how they
how they got there which is just a real
lesson for us human beings
how to achieve things that you just
truly want in your life and that are
aligned with you
uh then we also talked a lot about
relationship
there are a couple that are just here in
this life to grow together
and um you know vulnerability is a huge
part of um of showing up in a way that's
going to allow that to happen so we
talked about that we talked about
self-care
and then of course jp being jp he
obviously
made us laugh a lot so enjoy the show
danica thank you very much for
inviting us onto your show i'm so
excited for this
i i don't i mean you guys both do this
stuff too and like
i i get done with these shows and i'm
like i feel so energized like i feel so
good i feel so
i i you know sometimes it's inspired
sometimes it's just grateful
sometimes you know but they like i never
finish a show
and think to myself oh god i'm exhausted
i'm always so
elevated by it totally we'll we'll make
sure you have a grind with us
yeah you're going to basically fran me
during this workout during this
interview we'll give you
we'll probably give her like one word
answers i thought actually one of the
things i want to start off with
is to do more of a little bit of a
background on
you guys and because i feel like you
guys both had such different
careers before you arrived where you're
at now
which feels like such a a home for you
and so natural and also so fun
um so ladies first um
you were a dancer for 20 years right
wow yeah and then you transitioned
into um you know business coaching
uh teacher training retreats
and so i just kind of want you to you
know talk about how you made that
transition
from being a dancer of 20 years to where
you're at now and like why did that
how did that all yeah well it was really
a natural evolution at the time because
during all my dance training all my
years of dancing i had a lot of acute
and chronic injuries as a lot of
professional athletes do right and so i
had to learn along the way how to
basically prevent injury and
rehabilitate my injuries
in a way that was going to allow me to
keep dancing because really that was my
dream for most
of my life was to dance as long as i
could professionally once i
got through college and i was dancing in
san francisco for many years and so
um but i found pilates and yoga along
the way pilates specifically helped me
heal a really debilitating back injury i
had from a really young age at age 13.
um i had stress fractures in l4 l5 and
just within the chronic back pain and i
was going to like chiropractors and
physical therapists and acupuncturists
and like
nothing was really getting to the root
of what my where the pain was
or like the imbalances that i had in my
body muscularly that were causing the
pain
right so pilates taught me all of that
and i said oh my god like within two
weeks of practicing pilates my back pain
completely vanished
and i was like hallelujah i found the
method like i need to learn this fully
not only just for my body but then i
want to teach it because no one deserves
to be in pain like i was especially at
such a young age like they were telling
me i couldn't run
ever again they said like i couldn't
jump anymore like just nothing
like you never say to a teenager she's
got her whole life ahead of her
and like to just say you're going to be
in chronic back university life that's
crazy to me right
so i was just overwhelmed with i have to
learn this whole method
like i learned to potty's mat all the
apparatus all the equipment
and then started teaching that full-time
and that's really what transitioned me
i'd say that's what i was doing outside
of my dance career because i wasn't
making a lot of money dancing
like it was my passion but it wasn't
paying my bills in san francisco
right so i was i was teaching alongside
my dance career so that's what i did i
had you know private client base for
eight years in the city and i also
taught a lot around the world so i was
starting to travel a lot and that's what
really
um i had to travel bug from like a
really early age and so
i knew i wanted to teach abroad i wanted
to teach in bali and thailand and costa
rica and mexico like i wanted to take my
stuff my passions
around the world and i'm like i have no
idea how to do that so like how do i
even start doing that so then
i put together my first retreat and my
first like couple workshops and i'm just
like experimenting and trying to figure
that out
so for me it felt really uh
like an easy evolution because i was
just following my heart i was following
things that i really wanted to do
that really lit me up inside where i was
teaching the things that really mattered
to me that was also really helping
people i was serving them at the highest
level
and that really felt so good to me i
felt so purpose driven in that so
i just kept pursuing the things that lit
my heart up and that's really been my
life i'd say
you know it's how it's unfolded but then
when i moved to costa rica i opened up a
wellness center and that's when i
started doing all the retreats and the
teacher trainings because i was
taking all these modalities i had
learned and all the people i was
collaborating with
and just putting it into into like
projects and
experiences for people um but then that
led to business coaching
because it was like all of a sudden all
these people telling me
i want to create a business like yours
how did you create this lifestyle how
did you create this business in costa
rica how are you doing retreats around
the world i want to do that too
and i was like really okay i never
thought i'd be like a business coach
that was never my dream or intention
but now i'm in this place where i have
this information and of course i want to
empower other individuals like me who
love
these modalities to do this around the
world and help more people so
i need to teach them business so they
can actually do that so that's been like
the
natural progression
does the business part feel natural it
does now it does you know initially i
was like
okay how do i take all the things i've
learned and like give it to someone
because it's been like 10 years of
you know figuring out systems and what
works for me doesn't always work for
someone else obviously so i had to
really find things that
were more universal let's say and and
put together programs and structures
that
um could work for everybody so that was
kind of a process
learning process wow
that's natural evolution though so
what would your i mean for your quick
and dirty advice for someone who
hears your story and is like wow you
make it sound so easy
yeah like you just went from like oh i
did this and then pilates and then i
danced and then i
started teaching around the world and
then i traveled and then i did this and
then i went to costa rica and now i'm a
businessman
business um you know coach so what is
your advice like how
but there's a common theme in it right
i'm sure there's a common theme in how
you
got from point a to point z so what what
is that what is that for me it's it's
was always listening to my heart and
what really called me so it really
excited me and so
to me purpose is huge like i feel like
i'm really lucky because my mom taught
me from a really young age to follow my
heart and do what lit me up inside
and as long as i kept doing that i knew
i was living more on purpose
than for example if i did like a
standard nine-to-five desk job that
would
feel and i've had those jobs right and
they make me feel like my soul is being
paved over every day
you know and so i just realized like i
can't i know what life can be like if i
live on purpose and i live
in alignment with my heart so let me try
to do that because this soul crushing
path i'm currently doing isn't working
for me right like that was
my experience with let's say more
standard jobs and so um i knew i
was going to be an entrepreneur from a
really young age because i wanted to
create a lifestyle that really lit me up
that was like i wanted to see it was
possible in my life so for me it was
like i've always been a big dreamer of
like
i see other people creating retreats
around the world i don't know how
they're doing it but i'm gonna figure it
out
so like everything is figureoutable and
i can always hire someone who's
living and embodying that dream to teach
me or i can be like a mentee to someone
who's
you know currently doing that or
volunteer my time so
i did a lot of stuff in the beginning
where i was working with people
who were already living my dream like i
would go volunteer on their retreats or
i would go
assist and teach yoga on their teacher
training when they were teaching russia
you know stuff so it was like i would
teamed up with people and learned to
experience
what didn't didn't work rather than like
investing a lot up front and failing
which i did that too i failed a lot but
i think it's a willingness to
take big risks be willing to fail and
but continually following your heart and
listening to that intuitive guidance
because in general um that's at the end
of the day i think what's most important
because it means that you're always
going to be on purpose and you're always
going to be fulfilled
and if you're doing that i think you're
winning your life regardless of how much
money you make which by the way you can
make good money living on purpose let me
tell you
but like they do actually really you do
i think
yeah you do they do co-exist together i
think a lot of people think it's one of
the other
but um in general it's just trusting
trusting like that inner
guidance and continuing to trust that
you can figure it out you're totally
capable
yeah is there a story that you have that
shows the contrast between
a time when you listen to your heart
you stepped into a fearful place where
you're like
holy [ __ ] this could go
terribly and then i have no money left
or i don't know where i'm gonna live or
i don't know what i'm gonna do
and then the other side of that where
you said you know what this isn't
practical that's not a good
that's not a reasonable thought i don't
think this is a good idea this isn't
safe
i'm going to go this route because you
know this is what makes sense to me
in my head like is there a contrasting
story where you
followed your heart and it paid off and
then some other time where you thought
you were being very practical
and making the right decision but you're
like yeah so
now i'm here which is not where i want
to be totally well i mean i'd say like
the first
my first eight years since year like i
was
really keeping myself there and and
preventing myself from
really living like the digital nomad
online business lifestyle i actually
really wanted because i was pursuing my
dance career
and that was like my thing like this is
my identity i'm like clinging to this
identity even though it's a very short
career span
like most dancers are done at age 30
like they're not dancing beyond
you're lucky if you're dancing beyond
30. and so um
you know for me it was clinging to this
identity and this dream and in actuality
i was running myself into the ground
so i was working round the clock six
days a week sometimes pulling 18 hour
days just to make my bills just to like
do what i love
but um and and hustle and grind in san
francisco so i ran myself into the
ground for a good eight years doing that
um and so but i you know i finally hit a
rock bottom where i was like i can't do
this anymore there's got to be a better
way
and that's when i decided to up and and
what was that so that was the
what's wrong with that bottom for me um
literally i did not have friends i
didn't have people i was dating like i
didn't have anything outside of business
or work
i was in constant hustle mode and
self-care was not even a thing like
i danced you know some sometimes two to
four hours a day and then i'd go train
for six hours go train people for six
hours and then i'd go home and then i'd
go maybe go work at my wine bar job for
another five hours
it was just crazy like i was trying to
pack all this stuff in because i wanted
to still dance
and i and i wasn't making enough money
doing this hourly based training
you know i could only charge a hundred
dollars an hour so my income was tapped
and san francisco is super expensive to
live in the same totally
totally and i had good rent i was under
rent control like i had things dialed so
it wasn't like so
intense for me but at the same time like
it was a constant grind so i never took
days off
i i had like sunday half a day i take
off but that really wasn't
off i didn't have a social life i didn't
have any time to date
so i just was um isolated
depressed anxious all the time trying to
just keep this all
all the balls in the air so what really
shifted for me
and why i decided to costa rica is i
went down to i was invited to teach at
the vision festival which many of you
guys might know that festival
it's amazing definitely go it's
fantastic changed my life
so i went down to teach and this is like
early on the festival's history so it
was like their third or fourth
festival so there's like 30 people in my
yoga class but i'm like whatever it's
great like
it was fun it was on the grass you know
but whatever
it was so fun so i was there for two
weeks and what i realized is wow
these people get it they understand
quality of life
in a way that i was not living i was
grinding myself into
the floor and these people are living
this gorgeous
lifestyle connected to nature in the
jungle in the ocean every day
they're living their dreams they have
these amazing retreat centers and
they're just like
creating these festivals and they're
getting to live out their dreams
in paradise like sign me up why did i
not choose that
you know so i go back to i go back to
services good i'm like something's gotta
change
like i'm obviously connected from nature
i'm living in a high rise downtown san
francisco like
i barely got my feet on the ground like
maybe once a month
you know what i mean at a park so it's
like yeah so disconnected from nature
which definitely frazzles your nervous
system and totally takes you out of
balance
so i realized on that trip wow my
quality of life
is horrible and and i can't teach my
passions
in paradise if i figure out a way to do
it if i figure out a way so that's
that's really what
took that big leap so i left the country
yeah in four months i closed all my
business
i sold a lot of my stuff i um
ended up taking on an investor who
invested initial seed capital which i'd
never done before this terrified me
and i went to costa rica where i didn't
know the language
and i opened up a center and i was like
let's see how this goes this is gonna be
an experiment we'll see how it goes
you know and i learned a lot we'll see
if i can
we'll see if i can get groceries find a
place to live find the bathroom yeah it
was more it was just like and i had
enough spanish to kind of get by but
like doing contracts and dealing with
attorneys and all that like it was
it was not easy at all i was using
google translate on my phone
like you know just just stuff this but
you learn
you know you learn a lot yeah and what
i'm hearing though
is that i feel like the transition was
when you took that chance and went to
costa rica for the vision festival
but it was actually
such an easy decision it sounds like
almost after that like taking the trip
is fine
but it was like once you set once you
once you saw it you couldn't unsee it
and unknow it and unfeel it
and it almost made abandoning everything
else
it sounds like the only way i was going
to do anything in that time to get out
of the city like it was that
strong in me it was that pivotal pull i
needed to take me out of the city
because for many years i was like what
is it going to be
that's going to pull me out maybe a
partner maybe i meet a guy
who's going to take me out of the city
as i did like my lifestyle there
i thought i did until i saw what was
possible and then i went oh i want that
so so if i want that then how am i gonna
make that happen and i'm willing to let
everything else go
in order to figure out when what it
takes to get there
yeah and then once you start raising
your frequency and that magical way of
doing more and more of what you love
then you start attracting more and more
of what you love
um thank you for that so jp
you uh you were um a life coach for 13
years is that right
based on my memories uh that would be
true but i lie to myself often but
but yeah that's true how did you
how were you how were you funny in these
livestreams
no no so in the life coaching sessions
i would give my clients or if i'm
teaching like a workshop or a retreat
i would give them the very sincere part
of my heart
and it was real but what wasn't real
about it is i was purposely
occluding off my playful inner child
i i was i sold myself on a story that
said i have to be serious in order to
make it like i had a in my mind like a
life coach
spiritual teacher is kind of like
eckhart tolle just like serious and if
you're funny that means you're not
spiritual you're not helpful
so yeah i was doing that for 13 years
but of course in my my personal life
with friends and family
you know i'd be my goofy self my my
whole self
a life coaching i was my half self
um the serious half well i'm super
grateful that you've um
unleashed the uh goofy other half so
you'd call yourself a conscious comedian
right is that what you would say you're
such a comedian because it sounds
pretentious
like oh yeah i'm not a comedian i'm a
conscious comedian yet i also want to
own
that like yeah the reason why i do
comedy is to help people
wake up and embrace their their power
their authenticity and follow their
heart so
at the heart of the intention of my
comedy that
i'm doing so it feels good to just own
that
through the term conscious comedian
yeah well how did then the marriage of
the two come together right because
there's one thing about being funny
right and
then there's a whole other thing when
you are able to
weave conspiracies
you know um uh you know spirituality i
mean i'm just gonna
live and die by your how how spiritual
people argue
video um like to even start to know the
lingo to understand the dynamics to even
tap into
you know obviously stuff that amber's
starting to experience frequency and
energy and nature
and you know all of that stuff like i
want to know how that part came
in because that's like i mean it feels
like as much as um
you know you're a comedian at the root
of it there's like the the consciousness
is the
is the twist yeah you know so the the
marriage
was uh a clumsy orgy in the beginning
so you you know the these two parts of
me
were more separated just like i
mentioned like i can be serious life
coaching
and i can be funny in my personal life
but i had never let them coexist
so i'll give you an internal answer
first which will sound super abstract
and airy theory and it won't matter then
i'll
give a practical answer so the internal
answer
uh the work i had to do was integrate
these parts of me
so essentially metaphorically speaking
take my inner child out of the basement
where i had thrown him for 13 years and
said
you stay in the basement because you
will screw up my professional life
you're flawed like that was a
shame-based message i was telling myself
so i had to take him out of the basement
and basically say like
i'm sorry like not only will you not
screw up
my professional life you are the gateway
into what i'm really supposed to be
doing
i love you you're you're welcome in all
aspects of my life
not just when it's safe for you to come
out
so internally i had to do a lot of
self-integration and go through the
layers of shame that had compelled me to
lock my inner child in the
you know just all shame-based stuff and
then
from the orgy part kind of more the
practical answer now
i had to do what i didn't know how to do
just like how
uh you know a one-year-old they don't
know how to walk
until they try to do the thing they
don't know how to do which is walking so
my job was like i'm gonna fumble around
and make these
clumsy comedy videos where i'm trying to
express a
a sincere message through the language
of comedy i don't know how it's gonna
come across
i don't even know if i get it like what
the hell and
and i'm sure some of the videos went
down like barbed wire
and some went down a little bit smoother
but along the way i was learning how to
weave the sincere message of awakening
with the the language of comedy
so i i just had to do it just like the
one-year-old who doesn't know how
how to walk they have to just try it and
fail and keep going even though
their knees are skinned but you know it
i'm grateful that i attempted to do the
thing that i don't know how to do
and i don't even know if i know how to
do it now i'm still
in the practice of it but certainly what
i've found
is comedy is a language of connection
it's it it reaches the masses
you could be talking to someone china
who you don't know their language they
don't know yours
but if they start laughing you get it
there's a connection
so the the sincerity i have in my heart
to
help people follow their hearts and live
better lives
i i found like late leaving that
together with the comedy
is how i can reach many more people
it's almost like music right like it's
this sort of like
laughter and music are are similar in
their sense of
dissolving boundaries or differences
um funny is funny and beautiful music's
beautiful music
um so how
like back then when you say
i had to integrate my inner child
i mean even for me not all that long ago
that doesn't even make sense like how
did you even arrive at that
how did you even arrive at that
conclusion that's what you need to do
right like how do you get there because
i think most people
you know you go about your life and you
just think you're normal you think
everything's normal and you think you're
treating everyone great and you're
treating yourself great
and you know things just keep happening
to you and oh damn life
and my luck and whatever else and you
just don't really like flip the mirror
on yourself
ever you just kind of are a passenger in
life
so like how did you even get to the
point where you
knew hey i need to
embrace this inner child in me i need to
give it a voice
i need to not shut it down yeah you know
this might be unique to the redhead
species it's how
i operate but i never got to the point
where i knew like i've got to integrate
these things
i can only now in hindsight
realized that's what i was doing while i
was doing it i didn't really
know what i was doing but looking back i
can realize what
what i was doing you know i'm the the
way i work i don't know if it's my
astrology
human design or demented blue eyes
but i never know where i'm going until
i'm there
you know like amber talked about like
you know she she's able to better have a
vision
and then go there create it i'm more
like forrest gump
like low iq jp over here
there's a phenomenal quote in a book i'm
reading it's called
the lions trackers the lion trackers
guide
by boyd vardy the wonderful quote in
there
uh spoken from a lion cracker's
perspective
but it also it's how i resonate with
life and the quote is
i don't know where i'm going but i know
exactly how to get there
and exactly how to get there is the way
forrest gump did it
follow your heart and where it's telling
you to
take the next step i don't know where
that next step is leading
but i can tell my heart is more alive
and like jp of five six years ago
my heart is more enlivened making a
comedy video
i don't know where that's leading my
you know integrating the inner child i
didn't know what the hell i'm doing that
for
didn't even know i was doing it in the
moment i just thought you know i'm doing
self-working my shame
but yeah you know so forrest gump is my
hero it's just
any time personally i set goals a vision
of where i'm going it just messes up my
heart
so i do my best to follow my heart one
step at a time
what's the furthest you plan in advance
then that's a good question
not very far amber what's the furthest
he plans in advance not very far i do a
lot of planning for us
yeah yeah danica i would love to say
that i'm so
spiritual that i don't believe in time
and the futures
just a figment of your imagination and
i'm just so present
it you know and and i think i could
personally probably do better
uh planning like especially practical
things like we've got a baby coming
and if if it was left up to me it'd be
like oh let's do the baby's room because
he was just born
but you know we're we're now like
difficult
we're four and a half months out and
amber's got the whole room done
so i could plan more but when it comes
to following my heart and soul
i think the heart and soul speaks in the
language of now
so it's like i i know what my heart's
calling towards
now do you guys
live off of i mean i there's so many
different
sort of spiritual differences like so
many little
ways of thinking about things as far as
manifesting goes
and frequency and attraction you know
law of attraction
does that play into your guys's world
like do you think about that
consciously or um i mean given your
conscious comedian that might
may be true but um but do you does that
play in or is this really just a matter
of just you just
you have you just live your life in this
really present way
probably a little different how would
you say you relate to that yeah so
for me um i have a lot of self-care
rituals and practices i do to attune
my energy on a daily basis to help me
stay
grounded centered connected to my
intuition excited passionate
and when i don't do those things i
notice a big difference
in my energy field also i eat a certain
way i've been plant-based for 11 years
so
for me there's certain things i do in my
lifestyle that help yoga meditation you
know
they really help me stay connected to
myself so i can actually listen to
the wisdom that's coming in so i can
listen to my heart and pursue the things
that matter to me and
vision and plan and all that stuff and
that i i strongly believe in vibrational
energy and how that affects
how we create and what we attract um and
how we
for me it's all about like embodying the
next level version of myself so like
creating that person but then beginning
to embody her what does she
speak like what does she walk like how
does she dress how does she think you
know like
that's that sort of that's how i grow
faster
right take like bigger quantum leaps so
that's the way i think about it but
we've learned a lot from tony robbins
too
tony robbins is like such a master of
this idea of like priming your energy
field for the day
um with all sorts of affirmations and
how you do that yeah
it basically means you know stimulating
your mind
and teaching your mind that you're in
control of your mind
not the mind is in control of you and
awakening the body yeah that's my
interpreter physical getting really
physical
with your um let's say
with how you're priming yourself for the
day so he talks a lot about physiology
and how that relates to your mental
emotional state so if you're not priming
your physical body by like
moving and doing big things and like so
he has you dancing he has you on
rebounders
rebounders he has you doing your
affirmations with like a really strong
stance and like punching and doing
things that you're embodying it versus
just thinking about it
so he's thinking about he's really
talking about how your physiology
changes your mental emotional
and you start with the physiology first
it's actually like a
quantum leap quick start fast track to
shifting the mental emotional stuff so
totally and jp does that every morning
yeah
what do you do show me can you show me
exactly what it is that you do
here as a dance of some sort or
it's not i i don't do the dancing but
typically
uh i'll go out in the garage where i
have a gym and i'll jump on the
rebounder and
you know my priming ritual i'll have on
like music
that i love and then i go through what
our
we learned it at tony robbins this isn't
necessarily like a tony robbins
but just that's the source so i'll i'll
recite out loud
basically yelling what are called my
power virtues i am bold i am loving i am
playful
so that's the energy of how i want to
show up in the world so i'll repeat that
a bunch of times
then i'll yell out my mission statement
several times
i j p c or c here feel and know the
purpose of my life is to be outrageously
playful
and inspire the world around me and then
you know my my primary question that i
curiously
roam life by which is how can i be
even more loving and accepting right now
so that's like the the type of jp i aim
to be for
and kind of like setting that vibration
in the beginning of the day
and it makes a big difference i mean i'm
i'm far from perfect i still have bad
days but on the whole my days are
always better starting off a tuning into
we'll call it the vibration that i want
to live life
and take into my work and take into my
relationship
but do you do vision boards uh
i have before yeah and especially if i'm
working on a project or something i want
to do
whether it's a backyard or a greenhouse
or a house
or whatever i will start to like
screenshot different things that i like
and what's so crazy not crazy but it is
crazy when you first start doing it
is that you you see it in the end and it
happens and you go
holy [ __ ] it looks just like those
pictures you know it's something about
you that you you get to win a gold medal
in
is you take massive action yeah and
and i think we do our best to take
massive action too
where where i i like to call out the
[ __ ] on people who use vision
boards as an escape mechanism so they
don't have to live their life
you know when they okay this is the law
of attraction
but they also forget the law of action
is really freaking important
to have what you want as well
and to be who you want yeah
yeah and i i don't know maybe you can
elaborate
more on that and also like my little
like
flavoring in that would be just that
belief right like
that magical connection i'm hearing this
tony robbins sort of
style activation for your day to be
a way to connect the words yeah the
feeling
which then threads in that power of
belief too which is like you actually
it's like one thing to go
man i'm going to start a business one
day i really want to start a business
one day and it's another thing to go
i can see it i i can see it i see the
business
i i'm gonna do whatever it takes to make
that happen and you can
feel it and see it and you imagine it
and you can like you can visualize it
and you really believe it's possible
right for me to say i believe i'm gonna
i'm gonna go dunk a basketball
there's no possible way in the world i
can believe that's possible
right
i could have been so much cooler i could
have been so much cooler
i could have been a basketball star your
whole life away out of this limiting
belief that all basketball
rims are 10 feet high
or they need to be tall or you need to
be tall
but yeah you know i think with the law
of attraction
you know which it's a topic that the way
it's presented in
in the pop culture spiritual realm
i think it's it's tends to be presented
in a very one-dimensional
way and but i think it deserves a
three-dimensional approach
and i personally think what's what's
more potent
than like our thoughts thinking about
what we
want and want to manifest which is
that's so important
but you mentioned the theme word
generating the feelings connecting to
the feelings that are associated with
what we want
both the fears the excitements you know
one of my favorite quotes of all time
carl jung
he swiss psychiatrist i think he died in
1963
super wise man he said
feelings are the language of our soul
and so i think that the power of our
soul
comes through when we connect to our
feelings
but the problem is our feelings are the
scariest thing we're ever going to
encounter
like life would be easy if all the only
feeling we had to deal with is
happiness or joy but really like
anything outside of our comfort zone
doesn't just produce happiness and joy
it produces
fears shames angers like they're
and if carl jung was right that too is
the language of our soul
and and i don't think the the purpose of
going through our fears and allowing our
body
i don't think the purpose is to be stuck
in them
i think the purpose is to go through
them so they can shepherd us to the
other side
um you know through the proverbial dark
woods i'm sorry you were gonna say
yeah i know i'm just gonna um
add something right in there but uh one
thing i wanted to add to that too danica
is like one thing i've learned is like
pushing too hard is not the right
approach either
because i've defaulted to
like that was my default um most of my
life and so i've had to learn
the art of receiving because i've always
been like i'm gonna make it happen i'm
gonna do whatever it takes to make it
happen
i grind wow that's actually so
self-destructive it's actually keeping
me in a lower vibration
being this gung-ho and
pushing so hard and being so controlling
and perfectionistic and all this stuff
so i had to like
break all those patterns to figure out
like actually there's a fine dance there
between tons of action and focus and
also
being open to receiving and flowing and
adapting
and collaborating and like doing all
these things that i was just like
it's my way or the highway initially
right like i'm gonna just plow through
all this stuff and make it happen and
it's like oh i learned the hard way
hitting that burnout wall so many times
that's actually takes me into such a low
vibration that i can't even attract the
things that i'm trying to manifest
because i'm in such a grind so there's a
fine dance there
i am i was gonna ask kind of what point
in time you felt
maybe the most um emotions or feelings
because that possibly isn't a spot a
point in time where you've had the
biggest transitions
but so i'm still asking that but what i
also want to talk about because
i mean i remember listening to you guys
doing a podcast i don't know might have
been the first one you guys did together
maybe not but it was probably it was a
couple years ago
and um you know you guys were talking
about your relationship and you're
talking about you know
all of your own journeys and comedy and
plant medicine and retreats and all
and all of those kinds of things but you
talked about this sort of new paradigm
of a relationship
and how you guys um
you know weren't trying to be you you
weren't trying to live by the
prototypical relationship and how that
goes and being together every day
nine to five like do this come home you
know and you guys
traveled and did some of your own things
on your own
um so i'm just getting this feeling like
perhaps you know there's also maybe some
stories that have to do with the two of
you because
relationships are can really be our
biggest teachers
and our our biggest mirrors of like the
things that we're not facing in the
things that we're pushing down
or we're so used to doing coping
mechanisms
triggers i mean relationships can be our
biggest point of healing if we allow it
so
maybe it's been in your relationship
that you know you've had those moments
where you have had to
feel the most because you needed to move
something
through you so do you guys have anything
around that yeah
uh first thing that comes up and i'll
share about me but first
there's a brene brown quote i love that
you probably
know of brene brown she's only the cash
she gets the gold medal um but one of
her quotes it's something along the
lines of
true love is being willing to die for
the person that you
yourself want to kill sometimes so
which i love and to me that speaks to
the
triggering nature of a relationship
which
speaks to how a relationship is
one of if not the primary growth
teachers and
and for me i it is my primary
growth teacher i look at our
relationship
as a sweat lodge ceremony
it you know sometimes we crawl out of
the tent it's like oh cool that's
relief like things are groovy and then
nothing will produce feelings of fear in
me
anger in me or shame in me like our
relationship
and i would love to pretend in those
moments like amber did that to me
she made me feel this but it's just like
when you squeeze a lemon
the juice isn't being generated in that
moment juices have been
inside all along it's just being
expressed externally now you can notice
it so
i think 95 percent of the time the fears
of shame the anger
stuff that it's been inside and that's
why a marriage
is a mirroring of each other so i get to
look in
the mirror of amber and when i'm highly
emotionally charged
on my good days i get to ask what's this
say about me
and i get to own my emotions and own my
experiences rather than projecting on to
her
and getting angry at the mirror
i see of me in it so yeah man i
there's nothing that challenges me
nearly as much as our relationship and i
i say that with so much reverence and
respect
it's very much a spiritual practice
you know similarly like if someone eats
a piece of broccoli
versus drinking ayahuasca you'd be like
oh that broccoli doesn't challenge me
nearly as much as ayahuasca
that's why we say ayahuasca is sacred
and
we don't call broccoli sacred so for me
it's the same thing for our relationship
so
you piss me off babe yeah
okay um yeah so you know i
in terms of like a specific specific
story or example
like you know one of the things that
we've been really trying to
wrap our brains around is parenthood
because this is like the new phase we're
stepping into
and it's such a thing yeah and
congratulations i haven't like
taken the time to point that out but i
know that like
obviously i met you guys you know back
before you were
oh yeah maybe it was just before you got
pregnant and
um how much you wanted to have a child
and so congratulations what a
what a beautiful beautiful point in your
life right now yeah and you know but
it's also
it's such a massive transition and it's
it's um
something that both of us knew like when
we first met we never wanted kids like i
was the person that never want to get
married everyone have kids
and when i met jp i was like oh this is
why i never wanted to have kids i had to
meet the right person she was very
attracted to me danica it was like my
soul was like light switch okay this is
the one this is like who you're supposed
to be doing
so but but along that journey like i in
the first like couple
you know months the first trimester
going through this big identity shift
and ego death of like who amber once was
and who she's becoming and being in this
big transition period and then
me being in the process already and jp
being on the outside and being like
what's happening
how can i help you like you know because
he's not it's not an embodied experience
for him yet so i'm like planning
way ahead i got all these like books and
i'm and so one of the things that we're
trying to figure out is like how we want
to show up as parents and how we want to
embody an example a good example for our
kids
and so that's something that's really
kind of coming to the forefront is like
we got a lot of [ __ ] we want to work on
before
wilder enters the world because we don't
want to embody these examples for him
like we don't like the way that we
deal with our triggers with each other
right so how are we going to
find a communication skill set that's
going to really serve us as a
foundational language where
we both have like a common ground we can
speak from when we get upset
and we can actually be a better example
for wilder because some of the patterns
we play out are obviously old
generational patterns we've been passed
on to us from our families
and also stuff we've developed in this
life and so we're like uh
like individual work but also collective
work together so
that's been a process of figuring out
what can we do
we've got like four months to lease here
and this isn't gonna be perfect
we're not gonna be perfect we're gonna
mess up we're gonna fail a lot but like
at least we can prepare better
and so that's one of the things that
we've been just trying to communicate
better about
and um yeah so those have been the
challenging talks i'd say
most recently what are your triggers
uh where do we start you know
my just trying to feel like yeah
do you want to go first favor or do you
want me to you go for it okay
we only have um you know
about 20 minutes 30 minutes left in this
therapy session
you know my um my my biggest trigger
comes from my biggest fear
and that's when uh someone who is close
to me is
angry at me and and
amber isn't blocked by shame with her
anger so when she gets angry
she gets angry and sometimes there's
yelling at me it's
it's intense yet the proportion of
my fear trigger around that and
how i usually react to that as i
withdraw
uh sometimes up to a week so
but so my does that look like does that
look like silent treatment does that
look like leaving town
does that look like uh yeah like i'm i'm
quieter i'm more disconnected i'm
like i'm scared of her but it's it's
um you know my reaction to her anger is
out of proportion relative to her actual
anger
so from my childhood of my dad
screaming at me so like how my anger got
treated as a kid with
intense ferocious anger i didn't know
how to deal with that
so i didn't deal with that and here in
this mirror
edge uh amber is one of my
she's my prime spiritual teacher helping
show me and she doesn't know she's doing
this in the moment but her higher self
does
she's helping show me like jp here's
this
dark stuck energy that's been in your
emotional digestive tract for
36 years and i love you enough i'm
willing to be your greatest fear right
now
so you can have the opportunity to
process this and
integrate it rather than it dividing you
on the inside
so yeah her anger is my
my biggest trigger yeah which i'm
that makes sense at all just comes from
childhood i mean all we have to do is
just
yeah what's yours you know so mine um
i've seen
for example my parents play out patterns
in their marriage
that i knew growing up i never ever want
to experience those patterns like
and what i find with jp
what i experience of him is that he he
has certain patterns my dad has
and the and one of them is the emotional
close-off
he does if i raise my tone a little bit
if i
raise my voice a little bit the shutdown
and the disconnection and the emotional
detachment the uh the inability to
communicate at that point
with me is like like
the worst for whatever reason the worst
the worst the worst i'm like i just need
to talk to you
know how you're feeling like that's why
i'm trying to like express this stuff
because i want to hear you express to me
too so
that that communicate i think our
communication styles are
because of our pasts and because of
also previous relationships like how we
communicate when we're triggered is not
ideal like i'm learning how to tone down
my
anger expression and my tone and he's
learning how to
actually express it more our
relationship coach has asked
actually part of my homework is i need
to get angry get angrier
and amber's got to work on the other
direction which is
great yeah so well how do you respond
so is that when you yell is when he's
not talking to you then you just kind of
jack it up a little further a little
further so as soon as if i don't feel
like i'm being heard that's why i raised
my voice
right so initially um
oftentimes it starts out with a tone and
i'm like sound a little irritated
and then he'll shut down and not talk
and then i'm like oh but you need to
hear me and then you know so
again this is like my wound around not
being heard or being silenced in
previous relationships
so i'm like you're going to hear me in
one way or the other you're going to
hear me right
and so it's learning we're learning
tools to help us right now with that
because ultimately
we don't that doesn't get us anywhere it
just causes way more disconnection
than anything where he's stonewalling me
shut down
and i'm like well screw you i'm pissed
over here because he's not willing to
talk to me
and it just creates so much division
it's absolutely a [ __ ] show when
it happens to us but also i think all
relationships
when one partner's trigger triggers the
other partner's trigger right
and then that triggers another trigger
and
it's so we just compounds
yeah so yeah
it's weird that we're the only ones yeah
it's just because we're defective
just you just yeah i mean i yeah wow
well i'm so glad we're here together to
be our own little um community our wolf
pack
yeah but i i mean i i know that it's
intrusive maybe and i don't mean to
cross the line to ask the personal stuff
about that
um i know you're willing to wear a
speedo jp but i you know maybe there's
some things that you aren't willing to
talk about but i appreciate it because
in asking the question it's more about
showing people that
this is normal everybody has
problems we all have triggers our
triggers are not who we are
they they might be kind of who we are
right now but they're not us at our core
they're not us on a soul level and um
and also just because there's
disagreements or arguments or
we get triggered also doesn't mean we're
not
spiritual we're not conscious
we're not connected and in fact it's in
the dark work
where we actually are alchemizing even
more of it
right like if you can't just you can't
just live in this
sphere of like think a positive thought
and do a positive thing and everything
is good
shit's gonna hit the fan and we all have
shadows
and unless we you know tend to those
shadows
well i mean i feel like even in you
coming out with you know be
you know transitioning from life coach
to comedian is like
that was your shadow your shadow is like
the goofy side of you right so
like how can you alchemize it and i
think that you know
i appreciate you sharing that because
it's relatable
yeah it's so so important and
i think one thing that we're really
excited about is like having a third
party in this equation right now with
their coach to be like
here's your individual work amber here's
your individual work jp and then
we have calls together too but having
like tools
because none of us are taught
relationship tools growing up we just
like fumble through them
yeah talk about that i'd love to hear
more about this because this is the
thing is you can be aware like oh yeah
my husband and i fight or my wife and i
or whatever even my
child right like it could be like an
adult you know could be more of a mature
but maybe it's a work situation whatever
it is and they go
so well and that's where we got to this
point where we're like we've reached our
even though he's been through a lot of
relationship coaching this is my first
relationship coach experience but he's
been through a lot many in the past
and worked with different coaches and so
he has i think more more
tools initially but i was like i just
want tools because i feel like i'm
hitting a wall where both of us don't
know what to do anymore um
his way isn't working for me my way
isn't working for him so we need to find
a common language
or tools that we can both use but we all
both need different tools because we're
in different places like she's like
amber this is what i want you to do
because these are your patterns and jp
this is so yeah it's just been
like a big weight off our shoulders of
like okay we don't have to figure it all
out we have someone who like
can actually share with us like this is
super normal all
couples go through something similar or
you know everyone's got their own stuff
they're working on um and many of our
friends that are couples are also
working with this coach or a coach and
it's been so cool to be around other
couples who are consciously working on
their relationships in this way
and more of a preventative fashion let's
say
right where they're going to a coach
before things get really bad
yeah yeah i think yeah yeah oftentimes
like what we learn from our parents and
god love them i'm not trying to throw
my parents or anybody's parents under a
bus yet a lot of our parents weren't
living in a time where self-growth has
just kind of
become normal so a lot of them weren't
doing
conscious work on relationships so a lot
of what we learned
uh is coping mechanisms in compensation
patterns like
oh cool mom gets angry so i learned you
avoid that
instead of working with that and working
with
what comes up in me about the anger
and then you know vice versa so i think
um
you know it's kind of like you you
wouldn't do ayahuasca without a shaman
yet we always do relationships without a
shaman without a coach
and i man i i just think
you know as we're we're only two weeks
deep into working with our coach
oh we love her and we've it's just been
so amazing in these early stages i
just kind of kicked myself like yeah why
did we wait so long to
work with a coach but yeah man we we all
have
our [ __ ] like we're all full of [ __ ] i
think that's why god gave us an
[ __ ] to remind us that we're full of
[ __ ] we've
we we all have the inner yucky stuff
inside of us
and a lot of the yucky stuff that we
have inside that we're ashamed of don't
know how to deal with it a lot of times
that's actually our greatest gifts
we just don't know it yeah but yeah we
all have our
shadows to work on you know you guys
talked earlier about self-care
and so while there can be triggers with
each other sure
um you know i'm sure that there's
certain
points that you can there's ways like
you say amber about getting up and doing
your certain things
and um you know jp
you're both super fit you're you know
dance lean lanky
like beautiful fit and you're like um
i lift i lift weights i'm very strong
fit
and um but what do you guys do because i
mean i think that there's you know
there's things i can think for myself
that if
these things are not in my regular
routine
whether it be daily or most days
um it really takes me out of alignment
it takes me
out of this frequency where i can
continue to attract more and more good
things i can get on
really negative mental spirals and you
know usually it has to do with looking
at your phones for too long
um like do you guys have phone rules are
there like
phone rules in relationship where you're
like not after this time or not that or
you know but what are those things that
take you personally out of alignment
then make you easier to trigger that's
great um
yeah i'd say what what takes me out of
alignment is my workaholic tendencies
so my need to feel purposeful
is very much in tandem with my work so
if i'm not working
i'm like you know there's there's this
old story that
if i'm not working i'm not um valuable
which is i think a program a lot of
americans or western people run
um right so that that's an old program
i'm working to release and i've gotten
so much better with that over time but
it's very easy for me to default to work
mode and
that cuts me off very quickly from
my body my heart my feminine essence i
get real masculine with my work
i'm just like get you done i'm just like
you know uh task master
and so it takes me out of that playful
fun and flowy feminine essence i have i
just
don't always embody when i'm working so
that's what pulls me out and that's also
stress related to work so it's
it's both of those things together
because i love what i do but there are
days when it gets super stressful and
um overwhelming so um
yeah but like the things that pull me
back are always meditation yoga
dance exact dance is super cathartic for
me
um being in nature massive massive
tape i'm putting the phone away there
are days where i'm like i'm not touching
my phone i don't even want to look at it
i've been
sucked into technology on my computer my
phone all week with work i'm done and
all i want to do is be outside so i'm
like babe
let's go for a walk i need to be outside
i need to get out of the house you know
so nature is a big remedy for me too
yeah
i think there's three primary things
that'll pull me
into the swamp and i'll just
my days get worse because of it
yeah clearly lead to accidents on the
floor
just that video i laughed so hard
when that happens i just tell amber one
of the dogs had an accident she's gonna
clean it up
but you know for me the three things if
i miss a workout
or if i miss creative time creative
writing for
usually comedy or we
amber and i don't have quality time
together
those are three things that it's like
they
they occlude an artery that needs to
deliver
that nutrition into me so for me the
workouts creative time
and quality time with amber
what's your favorite quality time yeah
you know the
uh having sex is certainly up there
that was yeah high up there i actually
was asking about your morning routine to
get moving and then i stopped and
thought
that probably no i should have been
thinking
you know so like just to be frank
certainly having sex is part of it
and you know i love to be in our
backyard together
with our dogs running around like
maniacs
i just i so value that expression of
quality time
there's many things i love to do with
amber that we love to do together but
that one it's just like there's a
stillness component in it
we're not even on an adventure which is
great but it's like then a lot of the
focus is on the adventure
but it's just like yeah there's
something really special to me about
hey we're home in the backyard with our
crazy animals
yeah yeah i mean there's this i'm having
this
these thoughts about you know this
contrasting idea of like
quality time and alignment and
technology over here
but then on the other end of it it feels
like
that is what perpetuates and drives the
content
for the technology in a way right so
i was i'm kind of curious because you
both have such beautiful content
you know obviously jp with your comedy
and your skits and some of it has to do
with
you know current affairs going on that
you're willing to address
and brave enough to address um and amber
yourself too but also from you know your
all of your words your long posts your
perspective your
encouragement to be introspective and
questions that we can ask ourselves so
how do you come up with that content
what drives it mm-hmm yeah i'd say um
for me
so much of it is is just inspired in the
moment so it's inspired by things
happening in my life
things i'm learning in my life um
a lot of my posts i'm sharing a lot of
my own experience the challenges i've
been through and sometimes i'm writing
myself a pep talk
or sometimes it's like i'm writing
something for other people but it's
really for me too um so
i'd say that you know for me though like
my well of inspiration is really
movement
so it's hard for me oftentimes to drop
into a creative zone where i'm writing
something
if i haven't been moving that day
because movement like the wisdom of the
body connecting to that place for me
as a dancer is like that's like the
first kind of primordial place that
i feel connected to my heart my body
intuition source energy whatever
you want to call it like that's where i
tap in so
meditation is another great portal for
that so but for me movement is huge so
the difference between my creative
process after i go work out
versus before is like night and day
oftentimes because
physical movement gets you grounded
immediately into the present moment
makes you really present and aware and
that's how you can open up that
channel of inspiration to like receive
the information
or come up with the ideas that you want
to share so that's
that's how i tap in yeah you have to be
present i mean if you're working out
counting reps or dancing and following
the
sound and the music in your body you
can't help right present
yeah yeah you know
carl jung's thought our feelings are the
language of our soul
my feelings that's that's where my
content comes from so when i am
when i notice an emotional charge about
something
noticing what that something is is
usually
a comedic idea totally for example
this past weekend normally i work out in
our home gym
but i went to a gym because it's like i
threw my back out recently i want to be
able to
do a real leg workout without loading my
spine
through squats so i get to the gym
and they said you know like quarantine
kovid kind of you know regulations we're
closing for a half an hour to clean
we'll be open again in a half hour then
we'll be open for an hour
then after that we close for another
half hour to clean
and you know this like this talking to a
guy who
like i remember the cdc said this uh
infection doesn't spread very easily on
surfaces i just wasted my time driving
to a gym
and then i'm like wait in the parking
lot for a half hour or go home
so i was just pissed off i don't like
having my time wasted
so on the drive home i'm just beaming i
had the emotional charge going
and then this flood of ideas came to me
for the video
and i just got back i was filming that
video this morning i'm sure it'll
it'll be released by the time the
podcast comes comes out
you know with comedy specifically for my
content
there's always two prime ingredients
there has to be truth in comedy and
there has to be pain
and comedy and i know there's pain when
i notice an elevated emotion
so anyway i i do my best to notice the
bio feedback mechanism of my emotions
and usually that'll point to
what i'm supposed to do content um so
smart
such an such a an elevated level of
awareness
as a human being to notice that because
that also plays into so many other
things too
you're worried about something and you
feel it in your body and then all of a
sudden you're like oh what's you know i
can do that where i'm like
wait why am i anxious what's going on
and then you end up finding out
sooner or later exactly what that's
about and you're like oh [ __ ] why
couldn't you have hit my brain before
you hit my body
and the truth is it probably kind of did
at some point hit my brain but i ignored
it
but that kind of leads me to a curiosity
because you're such a power couple as
far as what you do
and your level of consciousness and your
level of vulnerability so
maybe you feel like you what is your
purpose is what i want to
ask and is it individual and or is it
collective between the two of you two do
you feel like you have a purpose
together where
are you here for a reason or do you feel
like your purposes align and what are
they
yeah i think yes and yeah please jump in
but i think we both have our individual
purposes
and then a third thing which is our
collective
purpose you know like i know my
individual purpose as i define it based
on what's written on the wall there is
uh you know my my purpose is to help
people grow heal and awaken
through conscious comedy and
what would you say your purpose is so
hilariously enough my mission statement
on my website says
uh i transfer i help people transform
heal and awaken
but i do that in different ways right so
we have different methods like his
comedy mine is through the body
oftentimes through plant medicines
through
meditation like all the different tools
business skills like a lot of different
tools go into that awakening or that
transformation but
that's very much what i think we're here
to do and so when i met him i was like
our souls are like on the same mission
baby so like
we could do some awesome work together
and you know and
bring our different tools because of
different tools and skill sets
and my my ultimate hope for us is that
we do work together whatever that may
look like
um and you've gotten to do that a little
bit in his videos um
i love i love i love the one where you
wear
uh the shirt and your arms
so inappropriately funny yeah that was
so funny amber is great in the videos
and yeah and i i think we're probably in
an ongoing process of author
our collective purpose certainly an
element of that
is to bring our child
wilder into the world and love him with
all of our hearts
and i would also dare say
other elements of our purpose together
is to
support the hell out of each other and
trigger the hell out of each other so we
can each be more whole individuals even
though we're like
screw you in the moment um but yeah
i i personally you know and i'm curious
your
thought on it danica my personal belief
is ideally in a relationship
each individual has a sense of purpose
outside of the relationship that way
they don't
need their relationship but they can
kind of like two whole individuals
coming together rather than two half
individuals coming together
trying to complete each other but
curious you're
your thoughts i think so too i think
that
um i think that you know your
best individually when you have a thing
right if you don't have a thing then
you're dependent
and you're also not really in that
elevated frequency of inspired right
when you're inspired and you feel like
you have something to live for and
something you love doing and something
that's creative and a lot of times tends
to be creative it doesn't have to be but
you know then you you as a human being
have
i think you're living more on your
true soul frequency or a higher
frequency that then attracts good
things and that good thing is that other
person
and you know so if you both are doing
that then you attract each other but
um so yeah i absolutely think you need
your own thing because you need to do
that for yourself
because if we rely on someone else to
make us happy
it can happen a lot or some of the time
which is more of the case maybe but it
will never
happen all the time yeah you can't
guarantee your happiness if you're
if you're leaving that up to someone
else you just can't
it's going to be a roller coaster it's
going to
be um unpredictable um
and you know you want to be with someone
who's inspired you want to be with
someone who has
a dream and a passion and drive
and um and purpose so that just like you
guys and that's why it's no mystery that
you're together is because you both have
like the same words that you have for
what you want to
do in this life maybe you do them
different ways but you have the same
goals and so
um it's no mystery to me so i think that
you guys are an incredibly purposeful
couple
and um i uh i'm so excited for wilder
like give me your dream like what kind
of world we're in a crazy freaking world
right now like
[ __ ] hit the fan on every level and i
don't even want to talk about the next
thing happening because
it seems to be there's always a next
thing happening and i'm over it like
it's this is like the breakdown and now
we need to break through
i'm hoping um so what kind of world do
you hope that wilder's going to
come into um after
the dust settles and the sun comes back
out you know a world that's unified
full of equality justice peace harmony
where we're all
collaboratively living together working
together supporting each other
a really amazing community atmosphere
you know where
um we dealt with a lot of our shadow
stuff we've dealt with a lot of our
all the pain and suffering that's this
connection happening in the world right
now i think is very much related to
all the stuff going on inside of us all
the junk we carry that we're unwilling
to look at
so by doing all that inner work we're
able to transform from the inside out
and then ultimately change the external
reality but
you know um yeah for me it's um
just envisioning a world that's more
green eco-conscious like sustainable
all those good things yeah i i love that
and i would add to it i envision
wilder coming into a world with a lot of
brave
people and a lot of inspiration
you know you mentioned that a minute ago
but i just
love the idea of our son
seeing living their inspired life
and people breaking the bonds of
peaceful slavery because they're living
under
fear and people being brave instead
that and that's already happening love
love
for more of that to happen i want more
of that for me more of that for the
world around me
but and what a what a joy to see my
son our son seeing bravery and
inspiration and and kindness and
love care for the planet caring for our
neighbors
i am i'm getting this feeling right now
like i need to ask you if you have
um a closing quote for us because you're
really good at quotes and you have
beautiful ones is there some kind of
closing quote
right on uh here's a yeah
danica yes
a quote from walter lippman who
says wherever
all people think alike no one thinks
very much
it takes a lot of bravery to think your
own damn
thoughts and fear
isn't something we have to live through
and have the tolerance of when we're in
the
where everybody thinks alike world
uh because nobody thinks very much and i
think
the miracle of our own selves deserves
the respect
of us honoring what do i think what's my
gut feeling about this
rather than believing what we're told to
think
through our parents media it's like
that's so
disrespectful to the miracle of our own
selves
so walter lipman uh believe him or not
yet his quote is wherever everybody
thinks alike
nobody thinks very much
i love it thank you guys so much thank
you for having us
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please